apenas una semana después de que se
hiciera pública la información de que
los teléfonos del presidente del
gobierno de españa' pedro sánchez y de
la ministra de defensa margarita robles
hubieran sido espiados con el software
israelí pegasus el gobierno ha
destituido o según ellos sustituido a la
directora del centro nacional de
inteligencia paz esteban el ejecutivo
tenía que tomar una decisión tajante
para intentar zanjar la crisis desatada
por el espionaje tanto a miembros del
gobierno como a los líderes catalanes y
vascos y aunque se ha confirmado que el
ente liderado hasta hoy por esteban fue
el responsable de ordenar el espionaje a
los políticos independentistas aún
quedan dudas sobre quién está detrás del
robo de información a tres integrantes
del gabinete de pedro sánchez esteban
que estaba al frente desde julio de 2019
fue la primera mujer en liderar el
servicio secreto español en sus 20 años
de existencia la decisión fue anunciada
oficialmente por la ministra de defensa
de quien depende el dni quien también
anunció que otra mujer esperanza
casteleiro también con 40 años de
experiencia en el centro y la segunda
del ministerio de defensa tomará el
relevo del organismo que afronta crisis
de imagen y de fiabilidad las reacciones
no se hicieron esperar y mientras que
los de esquerra republicana de catalunya
víctimas de este espionaje lo ven lógico
la destitución de paz esteban el partido
popular el líder de la oposición y el de
ultraderecha vox lo ven como un
injustificable ataque al estado y
califican el cese de paz esteban como un
sacrificio ofrecido a los
independentistas catalanes este cambio
de dirección en el de cn y como lo
calificó la ministra de defensa no
parece que vaya a terminar de calmar los
ánimos dentro de la política española